(smooth music)
- What's up, everyone?
Michael here to talk about
the most recent episode
of "Rick and Morty,"
"Rick: A Mort Well Lived."
This one has it all.
Rick starts a new religion
that's absolutely not a religion,
Morty's consciousness
gets shattered into pieces
inside a video game, and
Summer does a "Die Hard."
But something else stood out to us,
and please just go with me on this one.
The episode aired on 9/11,
and we don't think this is a coincidence.
It seems like the episode explores the way
in which religious narratives
and mythologies both shape human culture
and seem to fuel some
pretty serious violence.
Now, I know this probably
sounds a little heavy
for an episode that
features Peter Dinklage
playing an alien obsessed with "Die Hard."
- It's not every day one meets
a fellow "Die Hard" enthusiast.
- [Michael] But we'll explain
in this Wisecrack Quick Take
on "'Rick and Morty' Season 6, Episode 2:
Did 'Rick and Morty' Do a 9/11 Episode?"
First, a quick summary.
Rick, Morty, and Summer
are at a space arcade
that's been taken over
by alien terrorists.
Morty and Rick are both
inside the video game "Roy,"
which they previously played in season 2-
- Holy (beep)! This guy's
taking Roy off the grid!
- [Michael] and in which
Morty's consciousness is stuck,
spread amongst all the non-Roy
characters in the game.
Rick, as Roy, has to
convince all these characters
that they are in fact his grandson
in order to help Morty escape.
All the while, Summer is
holding off the terrorists
after Rick told her to-
- Just do a "Die Hard."
- Eventually, Rick and Morty make it out.
They help Summer to beat the terrorists.
It's all happily ever after,
except for the fact that part of, um,
Morty's consciousness is now stuck
in the video game "Roy"
that's being wheeled
into a warehouse, "Indiana Jones"-style,
potentially lost forever, but...
Oh, boy.
But back to "Roy,"
the game in which Rick has
to convince all the Mortys
to accept the reality
that they are grandsons.
It quickly turns into a
sort of religious movement.
- He's one of those cult people.
They worship some psycho named Roy
that says he's everybody's grandpa.
- [Michael] And despite
Rick's best efforts-
- You guys keep thinking
I'm a religious leader.
This isn't a religion.
This is actual truth.
I'm a scientist in real life.
- [Michael] This all
seems to be the show's way
of pointing out the often arbitrary roots
of various religious movements-
- I feel like every time I
explain this, I lose followers,
but this isn't a religion.
- [Michael] and the eagerness
with which people join them
and build a culture around them.
But this non-religion
religion, grandsonism,
quickly establishes a type
of in-group, out-group logic
in which those acknowledging
that they are 14-year-old boys
who love masturbation are in
and those who remain attached
to their video game selves are out.
This is of course a thing that's happened
throughout human history,
often with less-than-kosher consequences.
- Get down!
You're all under arrest for
being religious the wrong way!
- [Michael] What starts as a little
old-fashioned social
division based on religion
quickly escalates to a full-on
holy war, which is set off
when Rick struggles to tell
Morty that he loves him.
- Rick, I'll get every single part of me
to get on every ship and go with you.
- Good.
- But you have to tell us you love us.
- I mean, at this point,
even if he said it,
what-what-what-what's with the pause?
- Screw you! Wait for it.
- Holy war!
- Holier war!
- Holiest war ever!
- I guess the message is
tell people you love them
or you might cause a war.
The use of the term holy war
doesn't seem to be accidental,
as the show is clearly pointing out
how quickly religious
beliefs can become excuses
for large-scale violence.
And again, um, this episode aired on 9/11.
And the show isn't original
in making the argument
that religion has an exceptional ability
to incite violence and war, and fittingly,
some of the most potent
religious narratives
that justify violence
are, like grandsonism,
not explicitly religious per se.
While some would frame the war on terror
as liberal democracy versus
Islamic fundamentalism,
others might see the opposite,
i.e., a pseudo-theological
American nationalism
versus a region of the
world devastated by years
of foreign intervention
and military occupation.
And that's not even to
mention oil production
or Dick Cheney's business friends.
However, the conventional way
that the war on terror is framed
serves an important purpose.
According to theologian
William T. Cavanaugh,
"the myth of religious
violence promotes a dichotomy
between us in the secular West,
who are rational and
peacemaking, and them, the hordes
of violent religious
fanatics in the Muslim world.
Their violence is religious
and therefore irrational and divisive.
Our violence, on the other hand,
is rational, peacemaking, and necessary.
Regrettably, we find ourselves forced
to bomb them into the higher rationality."
So for Cavanaugh,
the idea that religion is uniquely violent
is often more of an ideological function
dependent on specific definitions
of what's religion and what's not
used to justify more rational forms
of non-religious violence
often carried out in
the name of the state.
It seems that the episode
might be leaning into the idea
that the seemingly decades-long holy war
between grandson factions is
a reflection of the absurdity
of lots of actually
existing human conflict
in which people are willing
to kill or be killed
over disagreements on religious
and mythical narratives.
- It's parenting like this
that pushed me into religious radicalism.
- So is "Rick and Morty"
using the holy wars
of grandsonism to argue
that religion is both,
A, often a totally made-up thing that, B,
is unique in its ability to
create irrational violence?
Maybe, but according to Cavanaugh,
it's a mistake to attempt
to draw a distinction
between secular and religious violence.
"We must conclude that
there is no coherent way
to isolate religious ideologies
with a peculiar tendency
towards violence from their
tamer secular counterparts.
So-called secular
ideologies and institutions
like nationalism and liberalism
can be just as absolutist,
divisive, and irrational
as so-called religion.
People kill for all sorts of things.
The point is not simply
that secular violence
should be given equal attention
to religious violence.
The point is that the
distinction between secular
and religious violence
is unhelpful, misleading,
and mystifying and should
be avoided together."
So basically, it's not that
religion is uniquely violent
in history, especially given
that, according to Cavanaugh,
the secular-religious dichotomy
is a modern invention.
Rather, it's that
absolutism and irrationality
are at the heart of
all political violence.
So unlike the Sam Harrises and Bill Mahers
of the world who argue
that Western violence
towards the Islamic world is justifiable
due to the superior rationality
of liberal democracy,
for Cavanaugh, there
isn't really a distinction
between so-called religious
and secular violence.
Okay, so if that's the case,
then why do we still
often associate religion
with irrational violence?
Well, for Cavanaugh, "the
myth of religious violence
establishes a reassuring
dichotomy between their violence,
which is absolutist,
divisive, and irrational,
and our violence, which is
modest, unitive, and rational."
Making the violence of the
other uniquely religious
allows those on the other
side to feel confident
that they're violent
but, like, in a good way.
- There isn't even a
God in the real world,
you fragmented putz.
- This also involves
the type of absolutism
that both religious and
secular violence have,
because both sides believe
they have absolute access
to some type of goodness or truth.
And then they have a
mission to expand the reach
of that goodness or truth.
And speaking of goodness and truth,
have you checked out "Wisecrack Live" yet?
It's our new stream.
It takes place every
Thursday at 11:00 am Pacific
right here on our YouTube page.
It's fun.
We watch videos, talk about
what's going on in the world.
We have a really fun chat,
and I, I really mean that.
It's, like, the best chat on YouTube.
So come check it out sometime.
We would love to have you there.
Okay, so these themes are also present
in Summer's storyline, as "Die Hard"
has become a foundational
myth across the galaxy.
- Every sentient civilization
across the galaxy
eventually develops the same myth.
In Centauri, it's known as "Tower Man."
The Orionese have their "Thornberg Cycle."
And in Andromeda, it's called
"foolish to have imagined
you'd be able to kill."
- [Michael] And the potency
of this myth has clearly led
to lots of very stupid violence.
- Instead of handing me an unloaded gun,
she'll hand me a-
- "Die Hard"!
"Die Hard"! "Die Hard"!
- [Michael] Summer only
reads this religious text
when it helps her achieve
her goal of killing aliens.
- You left your book in the bathroom.
I read it while I took a (beep).
I mean, mostly the ending.
- [Michael] The quasi-religious
mythology of "Die Hard"
is reduced into a mere
conduit for more violence.
- Walkie-talkie "Die Hard," (beep).
- So what is the show saying here?
On the one hand, they
might be pointing out
the seeming absurdity
of religion in general
and more specifically its tendency
to engender violence
amongst its adherents.
On the other, maybe they're
taking a more broad approach
and showing how, in the wake
of events like the 9/11 attacks,
politics and religion
can be just two sides
of the same irrationally violent coin.
- Better to die in "Roy"
than to serve in hell!
- [Michael] As Kavanaugh
concludes, "this opposition
of irrational and irrational,
secular and religious,
Western and Muslim is not
simply descriptive but helps
to create the opposition that
it purports to describe."
Well said, William. Well said.
But what do you guys think?
Did Justin Roiland and co.
make a cynical holiday episode for 9/11,
or has growing up during the war
on terror just broken my brain?
Please let us know in the comments.
Thanks as always to our
patrons for your support,
and be sure to be a good grandson
and please like this video,
subscribe to the channel, all that stuff.
It means a lot.
As always, thanks so much for watching,
and walkie-talkie "Die Hard," (beep).
(upbeat music)